hey guys how are you welcome desk IJ I'm
Justine and I'm fully prepared
emotionally stable sort of ready to
answer these questions cuz after I read
some of the things you guys asked me I
get afraid for our future I get afraid
for our children I get afraid for my
potential ever future a child if I never
have them I'm pretty sure they will end
up has anybody seen Game of Thrones do
you know that little monster or maybe
you seem lost like a smoke monster where
I feel like if I have a child that is
what's gonna come out its give it to
smoke monster
[Music]
the million dollar question is not any
the questions that you guys are asking
me it's a question that I have to ask
you guys can you see me it's camo
questions oh hey it's Haley asking if I
like eggnog I don't really remember what
it tastes like but I do have a haunting
memory of trying it and just wanting to
just do very bad things with it not the
bad things that some of you people think
bad things aren't I want to just take it
to the nearest bridge and just slowly
pour it out Casey
it says Justine did you see the Yoda
ornaments at Target I was there today
they had so many more Star Wars
characters than you got no no I gotta go
to Target so see you guys later
jakey's lastly now that you have an
actual green screen can we expect any
green screen music videos like old times
maybe a cache of music video for old
times sake I don't know why she does
have that one song it's no that's one
direction to live wow dude dude it's up
one direction or did I just make that up
right now Eric is asking if YouTube
never existed what would I be doing
right now
oh here's a good question from stink
wrinkles what I ever date a guy that has
the same size breasts as neat
well there's a question again you know
what let's just skip this question Jael
is asking who do I think of the WiiU
after launch I'm gonna be completely
honest with you I actually really really
really really really really like the
WiiU I know a lot of people have some
negative reviews and not so nice things
to say about it to those people I'm
gonna tell you what I'm gonna tell you
one thing I'm gonna tell you maybe two
things one thing is I have had a great
time with it I've had a lot of fun I had
a lot of quality time with Mario and
that's really all that I need to tell
you
there was a second thing that I forgot I
like supposed to know which Christmas
song that I think is most overplayed I'm
probably gonna go with have a holly
jolly Christmas it's best time of year
and it's only overplayed because it's
ever played in my head I don't really
know if it's overplayed in real life
maybe it is Ashley is asking can I eat
my foot with a spoon that I'm sorry are
you okay well I think the question was
actually something along the lines of
can I eat my foot with the spoon not can
I eat a spoon with my foot either way my
friend the answer to that question is no
Bethany this is a great question
she said would you have you ever killed
a goldfish when I was little I mean I
never actually intentionally killed one
I used to have his goldfish his name was
who no uno stands for one in Spanish
Spanish lessons with IJ today the scope
is you only had one eye and I'm pretty
sure they're probably had something
wrong with him anyway but he lived for a
little while and then one day he just
floated to the top of his tank and
that's that's the story of uno anyway
thank you guys for watching I love you
i'm doing vlogmas on my youtube.com
slash other iJustine channels so a head
over there if you want to see a video
every day from me they're usually vlogs
of random things so who knows what's
gonna happen I will see you guys soon be
sure to subscribe to all my YouTube
channel so you know when I post videos
but most importantly leave me some
questions below and ask me anything
there's just no guarantee that I will
answer it but it's good effort I'll see
you guys later bye for you happy vlogs
thank you